I was born in Iran I lived in Iran until
I was fifteen sixteen years old before I
went to school in England and then the
Iranian Revolution happened in 1979 my
family left Iran and I with them we
settled in the United States in Boston
it was right about the time that I
started my undergraduate studies at
Tufts University so the events of 1979
in Iran the Revolution the explosion of
Islamic politics in the Middle East at
the time the questions that Americans
had about what happened in Iran what was
happening in the Middle East why Islam
had all of a sudden become so important
were very formative because in many ways
I was impacted by that revolution
immensely and I was in American
universities at a time when these
questions were becoming increasingly
more important
well my impressions were not so much
shaped by my experiences in Iran but
rather experiences in England because I
went to school in England my school was
more like Harry Potter school it was a
boarding school with all those kinds of
structures that are associated with
English boarding schools and I compared
constantly the culture of teenagers and
youth and academia and what I knew of
England with America and for me the
adjustment was not so much as a middle
Easterner coming to America but as a
student somebody who'd gone to high
school in England coming to America
while we were in Iran I always thought
they might have a life in power have a
future in public life
my father was an academic he was also
involved in public life in Iran but also
once in America I gravitated much more
towards an intellectual career I knew
from undergraduate years at Tufts that I
wanted to be an academic intellectual
questions study of the Middle East
debates theoretical debates within
comparative politics history he always
fascinated me and also when you go to
school in Boston it's very easy to lose
sight of the real world and to only
think of a career that is focused on on
intellectual questions and because my I
came also from a family of academics
that almost was much more natural for me
to go down that